all right Tavi off at W Oh where'd you
grow up where you from I grew up in the
center in the valley and tell me what
your family had both your parents yes I
did
yes they did how was your childhood I
interesting I was like the black sheep
of the family and I wasn't getting
trouble out for the parents and I under
a strict strict um still a real strict
and my brothers my brothers and sisters
they were like kind of glue to shoes and
I was opposite I was always in trouble
around gangs getting gang at 12 years
old on the gangs yeah we started
clicking like when they would they it's
still today and up and going and you're
still active today yes I am very active
tell me about your first gang experience
first the experience is just basically
young just hanging out my new brothers
they became my family you know I mean
and I'll just throw my growing up with
any was like it was a different road on
my brothers to my buzzer was like I said
goody two-shoes and they were always
like Bruce Oh
snotty you know I mean good grades
whatever I was the opposite
I mean everybody rides great say I
attended school and did what I had to do
but I mean I I just go to school these
people always keep the hallways the
homegirls and hang around and then we
got a first of all the first of all was
just they came together and um and just
hanging out and I mean drinking drugs
wasn't even really a problem back then
it was smoking a weed drink and then
start using PCP and you know other drugs
it you know
now we're here like never you're abusing
them but just you know like the weekends
go use them and you know drink party
sharp up every not I ain't gonna do
whatever you got to do it I mean to
survive out there anyway we staying
around a little store my hood the parks
and
be like maybe like me like 50 60 was
your hand apart you know yeah you know
and then people are enemies to come
whether we have whatever I never whether
I could drive through it was a cool spot
so there was neighborhood small over
coming to my neighborhood and we get
into it every oh you know who's our hood
so we didn't know one come in you know I
mean they came in we're on him and he
carved my hood it was they you know they
were getting a bad end of it you know it
cuz you know it was our hood and we can
know the escapes and how to get to him
and how to block a me and you know me
because it was a drive-thru mall and one
cars this was cooked this way so you're
gonna come one way in one way out and
and we get him in the mall you don't
mean and they're being trouble huh then
they come retaliate or nothing and we've
been going back and forth we became - I
think 84 and 85 I lost I bought nine
home Boise and it was bad it was a bad
year for us you know me you know I'm
like right now I'm 54 years old enough I
survived all that I mean like I guess
dad has another plan for me in life and
I mean right now I strive to be a
protector member of society you know and
I want to do good
I'm trying I'm struggling and it's just
hard for me right now and I've tried
programs that walk my diction is with
ski me down now I didn't about I come
out of jail or prison I've been out of
the 25 years in prison
that's just CDC California part of
Corrections that I did that and I come
out of jail and I and I I don't know
nothing or prison I let him but my life
I lived before and for me for using
drugs it's not that it's not it's not
it's my downfall yeah but more more
enough about my old behavior because was
a goal beauty Oh behavior it's like
everything falls in place you got joy
swimming in and whatever else you got
you know I mean and gang gang life you
know surviving the gang life ain't still
today like I said I'm still like doing
illegal she
doing what am I supposed to be doing I
mean and getting away with it like I
said I wonder I want to be protected
member of society you know and my time
will come
I'm right now I'm looking on a few
things I want to gang intervention for
the youngsters you know I want to do
that for them I want to give back
something that wasn't given to me give
something that was given to me you know
me and for the youngsters give
yourselves a chance in life and the
wrinkles right we're growing up you only
know you only learn one way and that's
that's the way we we can use our
environment I mean people were wrong
with a bean what we see on the street
you know come on out of our front door
and just a gang laughing I mean so right
weave is like you really don't have a
choice
I mean you do have a choice but you
don't make the right choice you always
go the wrong way and I mean like my
thing is is that um if you're under 18
you should mean you're not supposed to
mean season you're anyways but you do
but you should make that decision to
being a gang a gang first you don't mean
like say um wait you're 18 years old
graduates going to be decide you wanna
go the game that's best thing to go that
around what I mean but my people age
with my school you don't go to gang life
and I mean you're gonna do good so most
of our gamers don't graduate high school
but you know getting you GED in prison
you know because my education was in
prison I don't know it's a plumbing that
my GED I mean and then I took the
presence prep program i passing City
College I graduated and I got a union
job but like I said right now my diction
is like my diction bring it down or
inducement
you know so is it a drug that your
biggest problem or is it the gang why is
the drugs right now yeah I'm extruding
right now but - what's your drug I see
but yeah pretty much yeah a lot of the
gang members it's heroin I struggled
like I said I'm strong you know the
court similar programs I end up [ __ ]
him up and I want to I want to know I
want a chance a
you might it's hard for me right now man
I'm really struggling dude it's hard
real hard
what was the prison time for brilliant
time for four different things of just
like assaults firearms possessions same
position for sale sales of narcotics you
know just things like that
carjacking like seven years for car that
I don't even do but am I gonna sit you
in my own way I took the rap and seven
years for it yeah just like that you're
all just no I caught a case in prison
jail you know and they said I'm
struggling man and everybody wanted to
do or you want to go the right way but
it's hard for me you know it's really
hard for me right now
it's gonna come yes I do I have a lovely
daughter that I love very much no
meaning and I can't say I won't do it
for her cause like it can't be done for
myself you know I am I like that point
that I was desperate to get right you
know I mean you know I really have you
know at stake
I want to do the right things you know I
mean I want I wanted to be they said I'm
protected members to say that's what I
wanted to do you don't mean for you and
your daughter's life um I just called
him I'm Matt and I my life really at all
just by phone calls and I haven't seen
her in like three years you know this
long time and I call my mom I don't see
her either but you know I talked to them
I got a phone but like maybe once a
month over in jail I mean even G I try
to call them once in a while but reship
I don't have I don't have with them at
all like as far as what I want to what I
would like to know right to be in their
life completely but I'm not so the fact
that your siblings walked a very
straight path and yours was very
different what do you think sent you on
this path is it just the way your brain
is wired
I don't know I just think it's not even
the thriller horror it's nice that's mr.
it's miserable
it's permissible right now I mean I
notice Antigua is stated I don't know
what's in taking me to get right I'm
trying out whining I whine I wanted so
bad it's like I just need to help I
don't know and the problem that helped
me it's take in the head with a hammer
and knock it in so I could do it the
right thing I don't know I don't know
what way to do many drug rehabs and
stuff like that
I've tried we have then I get I wonder I
won't try to rehab again I do want to go
to rehab I mean it's like it's a start
I mean to go in the right direction but
I liked it I came out of jail recently
like for money a month and a half ago
and I want to go to a program because
that working to in society you know
little by little yeah I mean like do a
the program they go to outpatient you
know stuff like that
so we're leaving and you still charge
the right thing but it's difficult right
now to getting a problem controlling a
virus as a lockdown intake what is your
biggest regret right now my vision grid
is of my regrets
I regret I mean
I'm just Restless I guess join the game
really everybody welcome shoes lifestyle
in loud you know I mean yeah yeah there
but what kind of tell me tell me the
craziest stories you've got from your
gang creating stories in the gang in
prison around freezing I've seen so I
seen a lot of things I got posted my
stress disorder from thing they seen in
prison down the street will die dude
item arms so prison is just as violent
as is outside oh it can be
it is a it's like you know a lot of
things happen in prison there then you'd
be amazed you know we like wow you know
people getting stabbed
I gotta start wearing the right but
we're all against the northern makes
against northerners the corner Latinos
little bit along with them so and we
went we get in the yard we can't pull
them together we start beefing with each
other and a right kicks up and puke and
stabs at her just for the same reason to
seem you know I mean state was what the
help no nowadays is not it's not like
that home where everybody everybody gets
along and we not getting along we pull
them together and every other respect
and and we should respect it you know
nothing going on the our transport I'll
say he said only now is think you know
need to be big I mean I want to go to
diva later you know it's like the gang
life we live out here is like is never
more and anymore like before before was
a whole different story around alluded
it's like water down and it's like
people already like over that you know
we kill each other back you know maybe
we get a murderer you know we hear the
song that killed before this driveway I
already it's not even you don't even
hear about driveways no more as it used
to be for novice Angela's going is there
maybe weekend saw that shot you
you know I mean you're still a shot but
for other reasons you don't even besides
gaming but he's dangerous I just it's
still getting your sire but a leg before
you don't mean I just people just do it
I can't I want to elaborate on all that
but the gang life is a dangerous what
you say to a young man who's considering
pull it opposite way Oh give yourself a
chance getting last night not for not
for especially the Hispanic community I
knew that we needed it all you should
need to be stopped being suppressing and
um and move forward I mean move forward
you know I know we can do it as a as as
a community we could do it and do right
do the right thing you know it's it's
it's gonna take a lot of work but I know
we could do it I mean I wanted to do the
gang intervention for the kids and we go
to school talking the kids it's not the
right way how I feel started but you
know it's I got to get some kind of
sponsors and some support and you know
they're leaving the right direction just
to get us started I want to set the game
straight I mean scared straight it was
done by LAPD before by 20 peers he's
little he's from Cleveland and he
started it with LAPD you know it it went
down but I want to start it again but
now the only people maybe flurry center
and I mean he's some kind of
intervention you know me
so the kids don't come the kids don't
think that that's only choice they got
is going to games they don't they have
there was a choice that could do instead
of being a game and they said that's
what I mean dumb fathers being a gang a
young age and started going that route I
was like man I'm 54 is all right now I
want it's time you don't mean you still
talking just to keep bagging Twitter
give to the grandkids where you get to
my kids going to make drink
man what the kid Shield Desert was foot
and she got you know and she's been with
her dad like you know no closer to me
she doing righteous over it but you know
I still feel it she could have had a lot
more for me and I would like to give my
mom back her son my daughter back her
daddy and my brother's back their
brother and you know and stuff like that
I don't mean I really wanted you you
know they don't having their lives right
now and now we like to be in their lives
it's hard I mean it says it's a little
journey for me and it's good I don't
make it happen I mention I make it
happen and what got me thinking is was
my I was too caught when they your
energy your energy was ecology
yeah what's gonna look like my kids
comes my daughter wasn't gonna beat you
know I mean Oh dad died of a getting
shot or dad died of a heroin overdose
are you knowing what's gonna say bye
what can't you say about me what does
she know about me does she already know
me know don't know me
and I wanted to get to know where and I
weren't hurt you don't know the real me
cuz I am a good person just I'm
surprised by you know I mean all the bad
things in life not one changing change
what I wanted that's all I got
alright Fabio thank you so much for
sharing your story had been you
you